good morning job I just had a few dozen
little candy bars John I got some things
I need to work out so if you could just
sit there for four minutes while I do
that that'd be great let's begin with a
story I used to live in a house that was
in the backyard of another house if that
makes sense my landlord had recently
moved out of the front house and was
renting it out to a new tenant one day I
was hanging on the back yard my landlord
was doing some yard work and my new
tenant let's call him Heath welcome my
landlord Snickers so Heath has just
arrived home Snickers says hey did you
pull up the the flowers in the back
garden Heath is like no I didn't pull
any flowers I put up some weeds back
there Snickers says oh they were flowers
Heath disagrees they were weeds and then
Snickers I'm just sitting here watching
awkwardly snicker says those were the
wild flowers that grew from the seeds
that were thrown at my wife and i's
wedding and then he says oh man now
you're just making me feel guilty I'm
confused about guilt I honestly am NOT
like the legal status I get that but the
emotion like there are times in my life
when I felt bad because I did something
wrong even if I didn't mean to do the
wrong thing I did it I felt bad about it
and hopefully that negative emotion will
make me behave in better ways in the
future like Heath didn't know that he
was like destroying something important
when he did that but he can still feel
guilty about it like if I accidentally
knock an old lady over I didn't mean to
I'm not like an old lady Shover but I
still feel bad about it right and maybe
because of that guilt I will be more
careful with my big old body in the
future like saying I didn't do it on
purpose isn't the same as you didn't do
it like you did it and so maybe in the
future you can act in ways in which that
thing won't happen again so that's one
thing I get that kind of guilt but then
there's another thing where I feel like
bad about something that I have that
other people don't have like I got a
book deal and that book is doing well
and everybody's excited about it lots of
other people have written great books
that didn't get published or like the
ultimate real-life example I never had
student loans because my grandfather ran
businesses and he was wealthy and I
never had to worry about that and I've
always felt guilty about that because
it's always been like present in my life
I've been very aware of it because while
my family wasn't wealthy we did have a
safety net that none of my friends had
when I was growing up so then I'm
experiencing this negative emotion and I
didn't even do anything like it
I didn't do it on purpose I didn't do it
that doesn't seem fair right to feel
guilty about a thing that I didn't do
and so I've always thought there were
like three ways to deal with that and I
was wrong but here they are one don't
think about it which is easier to do if
you only hang out with people who are
more like you because then it just
doesn't come up to tell a story to
yourself about yourself in which you
deserve the way like you worked an
unequal amount of hard and smart and
thus you have received an unequal amount
of good things or three feel guilty
because you don't deserve your
advantages psychologists think that a
small amount of guilt is good it
encourages people to behave in what they
call pro-social ways like you think more
about your community you help people
when they need help you volunteer you
donate to charity that kind of thing but
guilt is still unpleasant you end up
asking yourself whether it makes sense
to feel guilty about a thing you didn't
do like it's not my fault I was born
with money in the bank the answer is I
think yes because no you don't deserve
the guilt in the same way you don't
deserve the money and I don't deserve
ulcerative colitis or a healthy child or
beautiful fall days are really funny
internet memes
I don't deserve my guilt and I don't
deserve the advantages I've been given
because deserving is the wrong frame I
have that stuff and the question isn't
what did I do to deserve it
it's what do I do with who I take my
guilt and let it weigh me down and
terrify me and prevent me from ever
feeling good or do I take my guilt and
let it encourage me to do good the stuff
with the advantages I've been given
wasting energy feeling ashamed of
something you didn't do
no recognizing the advantages you have
and being motivated to use them to help
people who weren't so lucky
yeah John I'll see you on Tuesday